economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela buenas
noches comenzamos en argentina allí
avanza el debate sobre el impuesto a las
grandes fortunas de ese país
santiago muy buenas noches están debate
en ese momento no han votado todavía el
proyecto que llegó a la cámara de
diputados busca que las personas que
cuentan con grandes fortunas hagan un
aporte solidario extraordinario para
hacer frente a la pandemia se estima que
unas 29 mil personas estarían sujetas a
este gravamen y que se recaudarían unos
3.750 millones de dólares si pasa todo
el trámite legislativo el aporte lo
deberán hacer quienes declaren una
riqueza superior a 200 millones de pesos
argentinos es decir unos 25 millones de
dólares en chile hay un proyecto similar
santiago la diferencia es que en ese
país vecino no es la iniciativa del
gobierno sino de los legisladores de la
oposición
hablemos ahora de esa reunión virtual
que tuvieron las mayores economías
emergentes los países que hacen parte
del brics de qué hablar bueno primero
mencionemos que el grupo de los brics
está conformado por brasil rusia india
china y sudáfrica en reunión virtual uno
de los compromisos que de sus líderes
fue tomar medidas para garantizar la
distribución de la vacuna contra el kobe
de 19 entre toda la población de modo
justo y equitativo pero sobre todo a
precios asequibles por supuesto esto
cuando la descubran pero en otros
asuntos económicos
jair bolsonaro quien es el presidente
del único país latinoamericano en el
grupo hizo una promesa relacionada con
el polémico tema de deforestación
revelaremos qué países importan madera
extraída ilegalmente el amazonas' y
algunos de estos países son los críticos
más severos de mi gobierno nuestra
policía federal desarrolló un método
utilizando isótopos para qué tipo adn
que permiten rastrear la madera que se
extrae pero también la que se exporta y
seguimos hablando de países de la región
colombia entró en recesión por primera
vez en dos décadas
santiago la cuarta economía de américa
latina se contrajo en un 9% en el tercer
trimestre con respecto al mismo período
de 2010 y 9 todo por los efectos de la
pandemia del cob y de 19 un país entró
en recesión cuando acumula dos
trimestres de crecimiento negativo y en
el caso colombiano en el segundo
trimestre la caída fue del 15 7% la
última vez que se había visto este
fenómeno en el país fue en 1990 cuando
una crisis financiera afectó a los
países emergentes lo que se destaca del
tercer trimestre es que se presentó un
crecimiento con respecto al segundo eso
gracias a la reactivación de varios
sectores de la economía y después de una
cuarentena que comenzó recordemos el 25
de marzo y terminó el primero de
septiembre
daniela no solamente las tecnologías
están sacando el mejor provecho de la
pandemia quién estamos hablando bueno
hay dos empresas de estadounidenses que
acaban de presentar jugosas ganancias
entre agosto y octubre y no están
precisamente en silicon valley se trata
de walmart que en la firma minorista más
grande del mundo sus utilidades entre
agosto y octubre superaron los 5 mil
millones de dólares es decir 56 por
ciento más que en el mismo período del
año pasado también hablamos de home
depot que es la mayor cadena de
artículos del hogar del mundo sus
ganancias en este periodo crecieron casi
un 24% la noticia es para los empleados
de esta última compañía pues la firma
había subido el salario a sus
trabajadores de primera línea desde que
comenzó la pandemia ahora dijo que estos
salarios serán permanentes durante el
resto del que todas las crisis tienen
dos caras de la moneda daniel hablemos
la bolsa de nueva york que él cerró en
rojo el fabricante de autos de lujo
tesla subió más del 10 por ciento tras
el anuncio de su inclusión en el índice
standard and poor's a partir del 21 de
noviembre en europa de desapareció la
euforia por los avances de la vacuna de
moderna los principales índices cayeron
con excepciones de parís y en américa
latina' resultados positivos sobre todo
en argentina cifra el día para el cierre
esto a propósito del lanzamiento hoy de
disney flash en américa latina' las
cifras son los 677 millones de
suscriptores mundiales que se prevé
alcanzarían en 2025 las principales
plataformas de streaming líder a netflix
con 274 millones de seguirá de amazon
hb o max y appletv respectivamente me
cuenta cómo le va con disney plus en
daniela muchas gracias esto de la
economía en france 24 buenas noches
[Música]